es el momento en el que la brigada de
explosivos retira un cohetes smerch en
la localidad debes ludoteca bombardeada
en los últimos días
el misil de la era soviética mantiene
solo su carcasa la munición impactó en
el bosque cercano
antes de mover el proyectil tienen que
asegurar y medir cada paso pues podría
tener munición en su interior un mínimo
error sería fatal arthur jefe del grupo
lo sabe bien dos son stocks o
proceso traigan su fe pero posible sólo
trabajan con la luz del día acuden a las
llamadas de los vecinos y de las
autoridades locales para retirar restos
de municiones peligrosas tam ya estaba
escondida en su casa cuando un estruendo
la puso en alerta eran las 10 de la
mañana no lo vimos lo escuchamos al
principio pensamos que eran los perros
pero luego nos dimos cuenta de que no
cuando vuelan los misiles los perros
empiezan a ladrar
este grupo especial se juega la vida ya
lo ven recogiendo misiles trozos de
misiles bombas minas y también sus
municiones de bombas de racimo que han
caído aquí en jarquín olec tiene sólo 24
años y lleva desde los 20 trabajando en
esto pero con la guerra cada día es
distinto
lo que más nos encontramos son
fragmentos de misiles smerch o
normalmente la parte trasera del misil o
el tubo pero cada vez más encontramos
dentro de estos misiles munición de
racimo varias organizaciones
internacionales han denunciado el uso de
bombas de dispersión en ucrania o le
confirma que ha retirado este tipo de
arma que es especialmente mortífera
contra objetivos civiles por el número
de pequeñas municiones que se esparcen y
estallan
si encontramos su munición de racimo no
hemos desactivado por el momento minas
antipersona porque están en la línea de
fuego ahora pero sí que hemos
recolectado minas antitanque cuando las
encontramos acordonamos la zona
evacuamos a quienes estén allí
desactivamos la munición y nos
deshacemos de ella
estos son los misiles que recolectaron
desde que empezó la guerra probablemente
servirán para futuras investigaciones
entre los restos hay bombas letales
utilizadas contra la población civil en
ucrania